ah it's day 2 and I feel like [ __ ]
Amy's a little spotlight today that's
good where'd you go oh there okay so
we're gonna head over to the theater now
time to start the day I still feel like
[ __ ] but oh my room do you not see this
door with the giant star on it that says
my name that is obviously star dressing
room it I'm not even joking says star
dressing room it's huge
I'm so cool look at this see all right
this is I'm two lamps oh they're the I'm
gonna call them the lamps who's that man
who is you who are you sir with my
incredible vlogging skills I don't think
so I've already got a day of logging
under my belt and I am a champion
can you do this modesty you didn't you
can't do that face yeah anyway we're
gonna go on stage right guys so this is
the stage chase is the one that's
shouting into the void over there we're
gonna do our warmups
it's gonna make a lot of sense and then
you're gonna see well we do the magic
I want to talk about my penis hey bud
done my penis is so good you have no
idea
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks five things you accidentally put
on five things that you would do to
cover up your baldness five things you
would do with lock of my hair i braid it
one frame it Barry great abou doodle or
shove it inside of you five titles for
your Harlequin rooms romance novel that
you're working on my dick found the hole
[Laughter]
always hot her favorite color
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
hey how's it going master pianist are
you by here and we play you Diddy
Catherine please insert music right here
music welcome to my lair this is my lair
she's right here cone eyes are up here
that's what I said boom boom ha now you
did oh wait baby okay I just did the
warm-up and soundcheck for my VIP audio
thing ah yeah
I'm gonna go get dinner now you're not
gonna come along for that I'm sorry it's
just the way things are go um well I
mean you don't gotta go do anything cuz
I'm gonna cut to them anyway so I'll be
back to our still show time I'm sorry
[Music]
our honorees love you God that was the
worst thing I've ever life I'm sorry I
recorded that anyway so um it's been a
fun day I haven't seen any of Belgium at
all we're we're in Belgium by the way
Antwerp and it's pretty cool there it is
I guess there's not any way I'm gonna
I'm gonna let you guys go um we're gonna
go do the show so I'll see you after the
show's gone okay cool bye all right guys
I just hijacked the camera backstage
here let's go see what they're up to
we are an intermission right now which
just is a European thing that the
Europeans make us do ordinarily we don't
have a European intermission in our
European show but the Europeans were
really sticklers about their European
traditions
happy birthday Catherine everybody say
happy birthday Catherine in the comments
below or else alright look I'm not gonna
lie to you we're all gonna die out there
maybe or not know maybe I should take
that back we're all gonna be fine we're
gonna do a great show look I love you
anyway hey guys thanks for watching this
awesome vlog of mine if you want to see
more cool stuff go look up some cute
kittens on the internet because it would
be better than what you saw here okay
subscribe for more
alright bye
[Music]